it is time for turn the page tuesday rod
those teams that had the struggles i
don't really know who else you could
start with besides the dallas cowboys
dallas play denver you're thinking dak
prescott's coming back there's reasons
for nothing but optimism and it was
disturbing it was just ugly what
happened to dallas
well i mean if you're the dallas cowboys
you got to be ready at all times because
first of all you play on the dallas
cowboys everybody wants to beat you so
you have to be ready at all times you
can't take anything for granted they
were ready last week
with cooper rush and that's why a lot of
people look at mike mccarthy and don't
really trust him because you can have
cooper rush ready for the minnesota
vikings to play on sunday night football
and they can go win that game but then
all of a sudden you come back a team
like denver a very beatable team you
should beat denver and really you know
and that's why people second guess mike
mccarthy because how can you have your
team ready one week and then you come
back and you don't have the team ready
the next week and that's the puzzling
thing when it comes to the dallas
cowboys and you know you can't take
anything for granted dak missed a lot of
time so you can't expect dak to come out
and throw for 400 yards when he's missed
all that time and he looked rusty that
wasn't
you know at his very best but i look at
mike mccarthy and he just has to do a
better job of emphasizing how important
these games are because you want the
number one seed you want to play at home
you want home field advantage throughout
the playoffs but you have to be able to
win these games the games that you're
supposed to win and beat the denver
broncos as a head coach those are the
games you have to deliver on
yeah vic fangio got it done i mean i
think you're expecting a little bit if
you're dallas you're going up there
thinking they just traded von miller we
don't have to worry about vaughn anymore
this must be a team that's not confident
they're losing their way a little bit i
probably had all those thoughts going in
there we just won with the backup
quarterback on sunday night you know we
went in there to minnesota and got a win
we're the team now
and they couldn't run the football at
all i mean that's that's been the
identity of this team is that they've
been able to run it they've just been
able to move people again two awesome
running backs coming out of the
backfield pollard elliott and move it 78
rushing yards i mean they finished the
game with 78 rushing yards and they were
horrible on the money downs 0 for 4 on
4th down 5 of 13 on third down if you
can't run you can't hit the money downs
you can't win in the nfl and it was ugly
for dak prescott too
yeah and if you're mari cooper i mean
this is a simple play you got to be able
to make this play and you see dak moving
around you like to see that and just
once again don't have the chemistry just
off a little bit and offensive line gave
him you know did a good job of
protecting him this is another miss down
the field you make these plays it
changes the course of of the game and
then it opens up all those underneath
routes but one guy that i want to talk
about trayvon diggs he has to play more
more consistent he has to stop relying
on just natural athleticism and guessing
and start really focusing on his
technique because teams are going after
him and if teams continue to go after
him yeah teams are going after him this
is on the goal line right here he's got
outside leverage it's perfect but then
look what he does he grabs the receiver
you can't grab the receiver just sit
right there read the quarterback and
make the play it's no reason for him to
tackle the receiver that's a flag it
ends up in the score then you know teams
are going to run double moves on you you
are aggressive corner you're leading the
league in pitch so what do they do
they're going to come back and they know
you're aggressive they're going to
double move you with their big physical
wide receiver and all he needs to do is
push you a little bit create a little
separation tim patrick patrick is that
dude too he's an excellent football
player a lot of people sleep on him but
that's what's going to happen you know
you have all these interceptions people
see how many penalties you have how many
big plays you've given up over 20 yards
and it's so easy to get caught up in the
interceptions but to me i don't want a
guy getting a bunch of interceptions
giving up a bunch of touchdowns giving
up a bunch of penalties and giving up a
bunch of big plays i want a corner like
a jalen ramsey that's gonna keep things
in front of them come up make the tackle
and not have to gamble so much
now those are great points right there
let's get you to number two which is the
buffalo bills this josh allen bowl right
we had josh allen on josh allen and this
one was funny for me rodney because i
did an interview with josh allen
university of kentucky josh allen turned
jacksonville josh allen and one of the
questions i asked him was like how mad
were you figuring out there's another
josh allen out there and he's like it
ticked me off every single day because
every time i google my name every time
my name comes up people assume i'm a
quarterback so i have to google josh
allen university of kentucky defensive
end so if you don't think this was a
personal game for jacksonville josh
island you played yourself and he got
out there and got after the buffalo
bills how in the heck did the buffalo
bills come back from this
well uh yeah he played extremely well
but one guy that i want to mention a guy
that was with me in new england with the
patriots is brian offense coordinator
brian dayball and you know what what
he's done is he's fallen in love with
the d-pass
and it's like you have this superstar
young quarterback and i told you this
jack i'ma back up i told you this i said
the one thing that worries about worries
me about buffalo offensively is that
they have average running backs and they
don't have a legitimate run game that's
the thing that's probably going to keep
them from reaching the super bowl or
really going to that next level josh
allen is a great player but it can't be
all josh allen you can't be one
dimensional in this league as great as
he is and he's fantastic all those
weapons get paid a lot of money but he
has to be a little bit more patient and
go for the check down everything can't
be
deep down the field and it comes down to
your offensive coordinator brian dayball
you have to do a better job and and this
is my last point these offensive
coordinators jack they want head
coaching jobs where you're not going to
get that head coaching job the one you
want if your numbers are less so what do
they do they're not going to run the
ball they're not going to be
conservative they're going to throw the
ball down the field and they're going to
try to create bigger plays and i just
think that it starts with him he has to
do a better job
yeah and we've seen in big games like
what you consider those sort of premier
matchups i'm thinking about the game
against kansas city at kansas city on
sunday night we were there for whether
you'll start using josh allen and his
legs in the running game consistently as
a staple of that offense but a game
against you know
jacksonville they're not using josh
allen out of the backfield like that and
so the running game doesn't have the
same kind of scare factor as it does
when you're running the quarterback so
let's hear from josh allen the buffalo
version of josh allen after he went over
to city hall for a name change via
jacksonville josh atlanta here you guys
credit to them they came out they wanted
it more
you know we had a lot of
a lot of little things add up to big
things um
and i put the ball in danger too too
often
bit us in the butt played like
yeah i mean you feel like you never hear
him cuss after i feel like he's like one
of the more bland like almost like new
england tom brady interviewers so you
heard you heard a little bit of
frustration and anger right there and i
think rightfully so uh because there was
a real show like when you think about
what jacksonville josh allen was doing
sometimes guys just look overly
motivated and he was making some really
really impressive plays in this game and
they only had nine rushing attempts the
buffalo bills that gives you some idea
how bad it was in terms of running the
football
everywhere we go it's cold okay
everywhere we go we were in l.a and it
was chilly all right so
the temperature the temperature is
starting to change right now jack so
what is buffalo going to do they're in
the northeast it's going to be snow
you're not going to beat a drop back and
throw the ball 30 40 times can they line
up can josh allen get under center they
line up and run the ball 25 times for
120 yards can they do that against a
good defense like baltimore that's going
to be the difference between them going
to you know the afc championship game or
possibly the super bowl or them not i'm
not worried about josh allen i know he's
going to make plays
emmanuel sanders and stefan diggs and
gabriel and those guys i'm gonna tell
you one guy they do miss and that's my
man dawson knox they miss him because he
was really turning into a really good
quality tight end big fast athletic good
hands that's a guy that they they surely
miss
that's a definite that's a great call
right there let's get you to number
three which is derek carr turn the page
tuesday derek carr had a whole bunch of
struggles this week after really a good
run that he has put together through
extremely difficult circumstance but the
giants struggled in that game what'd you
see from car what turn what page does he
need to flip there
well yeah the struggles i mean yeah i
mean he had some struggles and things
like that it was a tough week you know
obviously you know he put blame on he
plays blame on himself you know the
interceptions and just
you know it's tough though man you know
you lose you lose your head coach and
then you lose a teammate a guy that you
love that you got love for and that you
you know you've worked with you've been
in meetings with it's it's tough man
because it's a distraction and it's also
a constant reminder that all it takes is
one mistake when you think about henry
ruggs you think about one mistake can
change literally change your life and
that's why i always speak to these high
school and these college kids and some
of these pro young pros like man you got
to take care of your business you can't
take a chance because one chance could
ultimately be the end of your career
yeah that's that is for sure i wonder if
they get aggressive in pursuit of a guy
like odell beckham jr at this point if
they if they feel like they need another
talent at the wide receiver position
that's a first round pick that's a high
level talent that is no longer on their
football team so i can see them going
out and getting somebody's they got to
be able to take pressure off of waller
they got to be able to take pressure off
of renfro those guys aren't going to be
able to carry this whole thing on a deep
playoff run so they have desean jackson
he's older at this point but i just
think this may be a team that's in the
market if they really believe they're
going to do something this year to go
sign a guy like odell beckham jr just
hope hoping that it is you know
effectively one of his last chances that
he would be mentally locked in and
playing his best football
and i i'll say this too you're raiders
you have josh jacobs who as you watch
him he continues to get healthier and
healthier and he's going to continue to
get better and better that's going to be
another force that they can use right
there darren waller he doesn't get
enough temps let me tell you something
about darren waller i played against a
lot of great tight ends shannon sharp
was a great athlete hall of famer tony
gonzalez
antonio gates two former basketball
players
those guys were great athletes darren
waller is a freak
like no safety no linebacker no nothing
nobody wants to guard darren waller six
six six seven
fast strong and hungry like he doesn't
get enough targets to me if that was my
guy
he would get 10 targets a game i don't
care who you have on them you can have
jalen rams you can have any safety any
linebacker you want darren waller will
get 10 targets a game
every every single game because that's
how good he is and he they don't they
don't look after him enough
ron how did you approach those type of
matchups like the shannon sharps like
the gonzalez is like how hard were those
matchups go ahead
yeah i loved it because and you got to
understand i came in as a young player
i'm in my second or second or third year
and i'm i'm a safety i'm out there
defending shannon sharp in his prime
like shannon sharp was that dude you
know what i'm saying so it felt great
because having a couple past breakups
people started noticing oh he's not just
a hitter yeah he's known to be a hitter
but he's not just a hitter a guy that
can match up with you know great guys
anyway but my whole point with darren
waller is he's just so good if they
don't have two guys on them throw the
ball up anytime you see him in
one-on-one opportunities throw the ball
up i promise you he's gonna come down
with it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports